makes his way out to the bump his eighth
start of the year an era of 2.72 a nice
clean whip base pads 1.24 walks and hits
per innings pitch and as gooby said
right he's in left he's neither one
hitting against him nice performance by
jp last evening and he drives one here
from ohtani deep fly say goodbye home
run jp crawford it's one nothing
mariners
what did he lean on that one his third
home run he's coming off a three for
five one rbi performance last night what
a start
there it is oh my goodness
that waited until the very last moment
to take a dive didn't it folks it's good
to see show hay bounce right back after
a home run by jb crawford
right back with a splitter that was
nasty
split-fingered fastball oh my strike
three
that kind of a swing by jb crawford
could wake you up and since that point
two strikeouts
swaying and a miss over the top of
another split-fingered fastball my
goodness that came out and it cut like a
knife that splitter
robert duggar will be on the mound it's
going to be his 10th appearance third
start on the year 01 1 with a 6-2-3 era
and 17 in the third he has 17 strikeouts
times he'll step in the bucket when he's
thinking he's going to get something on
the inner half of the plate
double play here
that's seeger the middle man
two down
incredibly patient last night
incredibly patient all year
he put him away with the fastball
elevated fastball struck him out on
three pitches i really like that
attacking him right away not wasting
pitches
95 with his fastball upstairs you saw
that swing on the first fastball
he was trying to lift it difficult to
have that type of launch angle on a
fastball upstairs and gotta buy him the
2-2
fastball outside corner strike three 96
miles an hour from the right arm of
shohei ohtani that's five strikeouts
turn it with one
two there you go
ending over double play good friend of
mr duggard in the first two winnings
an explosive home run by j.p crawford
carried 430 feet deep into seats right
center field it's a bullet here by
trammell
right fielder rojas gets to it tremel on
his giddy up and he is in with a leadoff
double here in the third
taylor tremell with his fourth double
that's going to get it done
nice job by j.p crawford sac fly scores
tremel two-nothing mariners
two rbi night for j.p crawford he's got
19.
upton walked his first time up
just it up to high fly ball deep left
field gone
did you jay a digit
another home run versus a breaking ball
for
jay uptown funk ties it up at two
back-to-back games for home runs whether
he's leading off
or hit number four in the lineup justin
upton tying it up 12th home run of the
season for upton and he crushed that one
way out
county seven out of ten in bay state
well hit hard right to seeger
and there's your third consecutive
double play
that works quite well 2-2 ball game we
go to the fourth
let's see indeed see everybody at the
ballpark
breaking ball hammered
it's got double written all over it ty
france
boyd put it in his eyes and
he knew what to do with it
he's reached base now 12 of his last 13
games with 11 hits
[Applause]
[Music]
just a teeny tiny slider at the top of
the zone enough spin to freeze him
and it was up
her up
i'd have taken that bat out as it's
fouled off didn't have the sound that
kellnik liked a nice play over there
bringing the glove yes of course it was
an otani jersey he made a nice plate too
there was
you know some interference the gentleman
in the puffy coat near him
puffy coat
with no intent i mean the puffy co guy
did the right thing he's just trying to
make the play but that young man stayed
focused
over the top of a split-fingered
fastball completely frustrated kelnick
with that one santiago's coming out of
the bullpen and
picked up a pair of strikeouts and now
the batter will be jose rojas here's the
1-1 lifted in the air hit pretty well
out into right center field it balls
going deep out into right center field
and that one is out of here
and that will give the angels the lead
it's now 3-2 third home run of the year
for the anaheim native against a lefty
for jose rojas
two strikes to count on murphy next
pitch he swings and misses got him on
the split finger fastball i don't know
how you'll be able to handle that in the
strike zone like he does just the time
he gets that chase like that
unbelievable sequence there and throwing
a splitter as a get me over pitch is
really tough to do it's tough to command
but then he went back to the hammer his
feel for his secondary pitches is
remarkable ruby i mean we are seeing
really a developing shohei otani
becoming just a masterful pitcher
got it split-fingered fastball
down goes seeger that's ten strikeout
with ohtani coming out losing the dh
now his mates his bullpen will look to
carry the water the rest of the way up
the hill
he got it that time over the top of a
wicked slider
boy three quick outs working with shohei
ohtani
vest staring in as the sun he wants nods
his head up and down trying to keep it
right here 3-2 ball game
[Applause]
wow well done
tom murphy will fast
cuts off that run at home plate
there you go what a play by murphy first
of all then how about this play by best
selling out clearly makes the tag and
holds on to it
what an athletic play by best cuban
native trying to wiggle off the hook for
his teammate got him
over the top of the slider two outs
gotta keep focus not through it yet
the o2
got him outside corner strike three
and the bases remain loaded
in his career reisely glaciers has never
been put in an inherited runner
situation with the bases loaded this is
the first time fly to left bounced into
a double play and fly to center
he hits this one well kel nick nice play
good jump
good closing speed to away it's a second
play tonight and both of them have been
against rendon
[Applause]
[Music]
now that's how you celebrate a friday
night at the yard angels three mariners
do that ball game